This master's book also includes leading
scientists and
experts in this book as well as leading Adam
and Max's lecture freely.
This mongering a so many talk is now regular
programming on sms he is a
student of Raju Famyan
and he has also done a couple of internships
with Acer Cambridge earlier with Microsoft
Research and based on the heal an internship with the
visual  Studio Team in 2009
Doing a Scope Plugin So only he has
three internships in one and a
day every week is only part of two
loops so it's an interesting case and only one
has had intensive interviews The first three
days are for us  This is for post position
in ry and amser in general and the last days
for sumis group
so it's quite intense and
ya so please give a welcom to mukan
and we don't want to take up more of his
time so please thk ya thanks mags
Thanks for attending this talk so this
is a work that will be described in my
thesis a but really like most thesis now a days it's a
result of a clebra with
lots of people so my advice
Rajeev Alar Loris Dan Tony Na Fijan Adam
Felik Sanjeev Khanna And  Custus Marus So Magas Already Mention
A Bit About Me But I'm a
PhD Student at University of
Pennsylvania I Work with Rajeev Allur
Over There I Graduated in 2010 from the
IIT at
Guwahati
And a One Sentence Description of My
Researches is About How We Make
Programming  Easier
a So I've taken
a couple of different looks at this I looked at this
question in couple of different ways
during the last six years My thesis itself is
about how you make new
programming abstract did at
MSR Cambridge for
example was how you  How Do You Do
Natural Language Code Search So How Do You Build Better Tools
Support to Help
Programmers in Their Daily Lives But let's get
back to the topic of this talk which is about how you do how do
you express queries over
streams.
So Data Streams Are Becoming Extremely
Common Place Now Today Here You Can Probably See
A Small Computer Network A Lots Of Data
Streams Over Here Servers Get Lots Of Get
Lots Of Traffic From Users Searching For
Items Requesting Web Pages So This
Browsing Activity It Itself Forms A
Data Streams  Stream Wt User Requested Wt
Web Page One If I
Take An Extremely
Microscopic Look At A Router It's Itself That's A That Is
Processing Data Stream It's
Getting A Sequence Of Packets On One
Side And It's Performing Various Actions
Forwarding Packets To Various Others  Sides
to various on various other ports so they are also
working with data streams at some
level we are not the first people to actually think about
data streams linear road wa
is one of these classical data database
stream processing benchmarks a i have
the setting  Is that you have traffic sensors
on road network and there is a car at
position x The car at position
Decisions based on how
much toll we charge users from using this
section of the
road so really if you look at what the server would be doing it would be
getting a sequence of
events on one side and it would be output  A
sequence of tools on the other side so it's
making decisions based on these data
streams
a In fact there is the whole The Internet of
Things is coming up so everything in the house
in a typical apartment getting automated when does a person
leave the apartment when
The person comes back to the apartment What do
pets do You have pet cameras Nav days When does it
enter the kitchen So you can ask
questions Like on average How long does John leave
the apartment during the day What
is the length of John's longest  Trip
Outside the House Questions Like This of
Data
Streams a So So This talk is about how do
you ask such questions and how do you answer these
questions let's actually fix a particular
example for the rest of this
presentation a which is a let's say to you  We are
working with a mock with a model bank so a
single customer makes a sequence of
transactions and this data stream itself
is the sequence of transactions of
the customer of the bank so he deposits $12 and
withdraws $5 a day whenever you see him.  It Means That
The Worky The Business Day Has Come
To An End When Ever You See It Means That
The Month Come Calendar Month Has Come To An
And You Might Ask Lots Of Questions Of This
Data
Stream One True Question Would Be
What  What is the maximum daily deposit the
customer makes What is the total deposit the
customer makes over each day What is the
maximum over all months Off peak of
peak activity
day A This is a very natural query that
a data analyst might ask how  The
typical answer is this so now a days I
think the most
straight forward way that programmers
approach a question like this It's not a very
difficult question It's not a very
difficult program to write or it's a
small stateful loop saying I have the
state  For each transaction that I
update my state in some way and at the end I have
some output but again the programmer has to
manually reason about what state needs to be maintained and
updated which needs to be performed after reading the transaction that is
how the programmer  What but what
program you actually think about
You are actually asking this question Average overall
month of the maximum total
daily
deposit
You actually think in terms of
abstraction More high level they think in terms
of regular expressions A sequence
of transactions of a day  A sequence of
transactions for a lot of days follow by the end of day
marker t star d A sequence of
transactions for lots of days follow by the end of month
marker t star d The whole star a They are
thinking about parsing the
data they are  Then they think about
computations that perform on this parse
tree a so so there is this gap between how they are
thinking and what they
actually need to write is
straight line code like this is where their
thinking is of visualizing the data  Like this so so really this
talk is about how you express this kind of
structured
queries over data
in not the data itself does not carry any
structure on it so in another way we are all
familiar with what regular
expressions are they express  Properties
of Language They express languages ​​so they
take data stream and they return true or false if
the stream satisfies some
property or it fails the property what are
regular expressions for functions how do
you combine functions
in what is set of communication to combine
functions just as  Regular Expressions Allow
You to Combine
Languages ​​So the answer that we will be
giving is an extension called quantity
regular expressions
a let's look at it with the same bank
transaction
data so we said that this was the sequence of
transactions of a single day so  I am able to say
OK iterate over all
transactions of t Combine the results
using the operator plus so sum up the
transactions of a single date and this
makes the sequence of transactions end with an end
of day mark because it is
the t  star d
so apply a to this part sum of the
transaction of the day take the end of day
marker map it to the constant zero and
then just d the just d a and the output of d so
so this function over here is define this
function  g is defined only for streams t and
with d and in that case it is basically the
sum of the transactions
if the maximum deposit over the month so a takes lots of
days and its input applies g
to each single day and combines the result
using the operator  Max So
Max Over R Plus J R Operators in the
Cost Domain Ways to Combine
Numbers Ten Operators Iter Split J R Ways
to Combine
Function The Sequence of the Transactions Or at the
End of the Calendar Month Than the End of Month
Marker So Take the Maximum  Over the
transactions of the
month map the month itself to zero and add the two
results and really this was the query that we are
interested in average over all
months of K
so the final answer is the final query that we
really want to write it down  Of Combine the
Results Using Averages What We're Doing Here We're
Really Building Up Function
Gluing Function Together Using the Small Set
of Combinations You Know What I'm Not Telling You How to Do
The
Passing Saying That There's a  Way to Split
It Into Individual Months The Transactions
of a Month I Can Some How Split It Into
Individual Days I Don't Tell You How I Just Tell
You That You Should
So A This leads to natural so this is a
declarative programming style so there it
Should naturally lead to a question of how do we
actually evaluate these functions in your
mind and that will be the focus of half of this talk How do we
evaluate these functions on their own but before we do that let's just actually write
down the comparison make  Sure that we're
speaking the same
language so the basic combitube
split I have a long data stream over here I split it into two
parts a
prefix and a suffix I apply e to the
prefix f to the suffix and combine the
results using this combination
u  Of
I mean it's regular expression problem there's
just one major difference two is
in regular expression I'm usually not
interested in this notion of ambiguous so what would have happened what am I telling you I'm saying split
the data stream apply e  To
the Prefix F to the
Suffix I'm not telling you how to
split it and in particular I there the tip
splits when it is unclear its function and
of two things you wanted so what we
require is that it should be unmissable where it should be
unique  The way to split this and only then is
the function defined is generally
an important theme around the function you are
not interested in.
The text programs buzz you know at
property part program or any piece of it is
a property that comes up in a muddler they so each
sub expression has to be ambiguous if any
particular sub expression is ambiguous then we say the
no the dimming of the
trucks  Does include you marker to be able to compose it as per your requirement as I know the
definition as a runes
tool part of the whole tool looks at g
and cert if this is
It can be done in simple
time with some clever algorithm so we don't even need to do that do the
silly things and
you will still end up with the silly exponential
algorithm is still fast enough for
not only this particular data but also  There Are Too Many
Too Many There Are Too Many About It
Took a more heavy handed approach what is to say across
all data screams it has to
be an unambiguous
and I will come back to that
question when we are talking about the evaluation
algorithms but yes
our approach will work a for ease let's say it
has  To Be Ambiguous Across All Data
Streams So It Dozen Matter If There Is No
Pass For Some Stream But For Each Stream There Has To Be At
Most
One
So We Already Look At Split Iter Is The
Next Regular Expression Quite
Star So I Take The Whole  Data stream I
split it into lots of parts Apply e
to each part Combine the results using auth
again Defined only if the split is
unique and it's unambiguous Clear
star
the next comes It's
like regular expression uni if ​​auth
e defined then output auth arvaz
Output ad
Now coming back to your question of e it
static and dynamic a definition is very
dynamic in some
sense but
no less to the question demand is the dome of e and f
b disjoint because it should be so we
loosely request that
e and have disjoints because it leads
to complexity with how
fast we can elute the stream it is
related to lots of problems open problems regarding how do you
match in
regular
expression something that you don't see in
regular expression a is traditional is combine
to function it  Self So May I
Have A Sequence Of Sequence Of
Transactions From A Bank Sum Of Them Are
Alice's Transactions Sum Of Them Are Bob's
Transactions I Want To Find Out Who
Deposited More Money Alice And Bob So Max
Of Alice's Total Deposits Comma Bob's Total
Deposit So  i take the whole data stream pass
it to an expression e pass it to an
expression f combine the results using a this
is related to something in regular
expressions why you traditionally don't see which
is language intersection this is only
defined if both e and f so  The result is
only defined if both e and f are
defined if and we are going back to an
ambiguity really what we would require here is that
e and f have identical total
domain but it does not a so I am not saying they compute
the  Same function if they have identical
domain so both Alice's total deposit and Bob's
total deposit take the anta data stream as an
input they compute different things of the
data
stream but in the regular expression world this
is language
intersection now what I've done in the  The
Previous Few Slides Really Introduced
a Bunch
of Function Combinations and
Else But I'll Also Make a Complaint Immediately
That These Combinations Generalize Very Well What I Mean by They Are
Not
Generalizing Well
How You Did Split Of e f What If A Was
Not Commuter What If You Wanted To
Merge Them In The Other Direction A
Over Here I This Is The Method For
Splitting The Stream Into Multiple Parts
Apply e To Each Part Combine The Results
Using
A  Delay if you want something lock this you want
operator to be associative what if this is not
associative
and initially you might think the OK may be that is a
very pedant
problem that is everything is something is not
associative or code and what if you really
want  To total deposits minus total
wagers
and the are commonest
in practice so because we are
speaking the same language here I don't know how
commonly referring to things in the real
world is a way to glue function together so
split iter can connect like that and  The operator them themselves
belong to the cost domain so how do
you combine numbers plus minus min max
average and sono this a so so this was
one of
the most important technical problems
in the thesis that I said there is how do
you generalize this to  Work with Arbitrary
Operators So what we really want to say is that we want a language where we give you the
communication to tell us that this is the way you
glue numbers together
so you tell us the operators
We give you the combitube and the rest three just works we can just combine the two
unknown to the operators that you
choose and solution or really have to think about what is happening
with our evaluating
function so this is the sequence of
transaction from the bank and we pass
Sequence of transactions f the bank so t
star d wa transaction of single day t
star t study lot of t study become a t
star d the whole star
m What we did then do we wanted to
calculate the maximum deposit so we took this
purse tree  And we simply replace every
node in the parse tree with some
operator so we there was n end of day marker here we
replace it with a zero n end of
day marker here we replace that with a zero and
end of day marker we replace with zero
m replace with a
zero t star the star becomes a plus t star yr
becomes a
plus star d becomes a plus plus t star
d the whole star a becomes a max so every we took this
pass tree that we got replace every
node in this pass tree with  n operator and we get
another expression tree and let's say
computation tree f and then evaluated to get the answer
but really the way I defined them was the com comer
introduce slit at map
stream to
value but actually not passing to what you are
Doing this whole thing or passing the data
stream replacing a node in the past
operator or computing the resulting
tree so the important generala is that we have to
map things to values ​​they can map
things to terms to partially
evaluated computation trees  What do I mean by that this is the
QR that I describe so far
compute computation trees like that they can instantiate leave value at
holes so max of 1
p + 3 and then
sumbalpuri p with the value f
so what you get is an accepted expression
Tree a n output fm many more than a single
numerical
value so how does this work this wa how the
previous slit
combination e and a the more general split
commonest
maps just e evaluates to an expression
tree f pram evaluates to an expression
tree
Substitute Substitute in the  The parameter p of
f prm the value e so for example what f
prm should have been returning in the previous
case wa f - p if f prm returns f the term
f - p then this it self computes the
expression split e minus if it returns
on  The other hand p - f then you'd have been
computing split e minus with the other direction so so this
is a generalization of how
the split
communication domain so this is really what in
the most general sense of the word these are the
basic functions  Just As You Have Basic
Languages ​​Map a Single Element to Sum
Value Map the MT Data Stream to Sum
Value Regular Expression Union Dictionary Change
a Substitute the result of e into the
parameter p of f Substitute the result of
f into the parameter p of
e  A generalization for iteration as well this gives you an additional
combination now because we are
returning terms we can also do
substitution over
terms and what this also
tells us
Here's Really Speaking About
Numeric About Numerical Values ​​Nothing
below this line is speaking about regular
common worlds we just glue together on
the
fly Basic function refers to the pretty low
can be used and any
function so really we got much [ __ ]  What I
Wanted I Said Regular Expression Function
Sigar To Bal And L Amp Given Function Sig S Real No Take This
Slide Here Are
Ten You Are Thinking of Numerical
Operators Plus Minus Min Max
Thinking of String and String How to Connect You Get
a Way  To combine string to
function from strings to strings
together
so pick up an arbitrary domain instant
the calculus not the previous slide and you get
a set of class of functions which is
expressible and we claim that the class
of functions you can express is rob  With a
respect to that choice of
comminution
so I describe the QRE calculus to
you there is nothing more to the QRE
calculus if you are a programmer that you need to know but as
researchers we have to other
questions that we want that we  Are
interested in how quickly we can
find because this is a declarative notation in an
actual
programmer Imagine you had a stream of a
million elements coming at you and you're anything that
super linear actual
programmers are not going to use them so ideally what we want
is just  One Online Pass
Over Your Data Stream And We Want To
Compute
Second Age Threat
J People Interested In Programming
Languages ​​We Want To Know What Kind Of Functions We Can
Express The Semantics
Of
A
And what closure properties do those
functions have so this will be the remaining
to a parts of the
talk or talk about the quickness of evaluation
so it's also the memory state ligation so do
you actually worry about that and we we worried
now okay so you  Will cover that I'll cover OK
in fact it's rather interesting so
if I go back a few slides a bit of
historical background how this started
was and gave a calculus for sigma star to
gamma star first country to what I
described in the thesis  And Then I Give
My Thesis Proposal Presentation When Some Buddy
in the Committee Asks Me Exactly This
Question And part of the generalization to
Sigma Star is to
actually be very conscious about what
memory usage we have
and really I think what we have is the
best.  Answer That Anybody Could Give If We Take
An Input Stream And We Are Mapping An
Output Stream We Have To Store That
Output Some Because You Can't Do Things Like
Reverse Stream So We Have To We Can't
Generate Outputs Online So Because We Have To
Store That  Stream this we need linear memory
sigma star to a we can give you constant
memory depending on what
combitube so let's pick up
simple re over here what is this doing you don't really need to understand what because if
the
stream ends with a b then just  Return the
length of the stream
if it ends then return twise the length
of the stream lets say this i this i the
many of
interest so ideally speaking what a
programmer would have done would have been to
manipulate the state by hand figure out  Vt
state needs to be maintained updated so keep two variables
Vt is the length of the stream
Vt is the length of the stream and manually reason about this Vt
control state do we need to maintain
specifically for split e a e
defined on so this is the enter  Stream
A Let Se Reading Stream Left Right At This
Point We Defined We Discover So We Have to
Start Evaluating at
Point But We Cannot Stop Evaluating E Because
E Defined on Multiple Prefixes What We Se
E Has to Be  Defined on the
Prefix F Has to Be Defined on the
Suffix May Be This Is the Correct Way to
Split the Stream If We Had Tried to
Evaluate A On This Part of the Stream It Had Been
Undefined So We Have One We Can't
Stop Evaluating  e just because we see
a point r it e defined na na the
split e prolly y e
in fact yn see it or so there is a
slit of a star so let's ignore let's
ignore this hole put this na a
star b so a starred b na  No I See A
Star It Matches I Have To
Start Even Eating The B But If I Don't See That Thread Does Whenever I See
A New
Combination
So This Can
Happen But You Are Right To Some
Extent Ch This Is A Generalization Of What You Say
Holds  If I think about it in terms
of NF evaluation and the streams are if the
expression is ambiguous
the number of potential py streams that I have
is bounded by the number of states
in this
NF if because it is ambiguous no to stay
no to  Potential past trees can reach the same
state because that would have
demonstrated a stick
ambiguous
and so the number of potential past trees
that we have is bounded by the number of
states in the AFA it is independent of the
length of the input stream so I can  See a
million tuples A million tuples in my stream but I can still have
just six
potential parse
trees so we're bound by the amount of
control state we need to maintain like this What about
the intermediate result So what do
I say that  Why Maps Streams
to
Terms and Ten Terms Might Be Very Large How
Big Can Ten Terms Get So in the
Case of Strings We Have to Store the Whole
Term We Can't Do Anything About It But
If We're Dealing with Numbers Over Here Than
a  We Can Apply a Basic Algebraic
Rules to Evaluate Common Sub
So you can bubble it down and
you can instantly store 10+ 6 16 and 6 p
6 so many p p 12 so this what and
up happening t ch term odd
number or parameter need just small amount of
space t store the result  In
Fact Or And So If If
The Co If The Operators To Use Are Plus Minus
Min Max
Average The Space To You Use Bounded By Some Normal
Size
Expression But The Reality Of Not
Sufficient Let's Think About Ater Average Rat How Would You So I
Give  You The Stream Of Values
Over Here
227 And I Say Compute The Average Of Stream
How Did This You Just Need To Maintain Two
Bits Of Data
I How Many Values ​​Have I Seen So Far
While Some But Let's
Think About Different  Query What If We Do To
Compute The Mean A While This
Classical Low Bund Online Althe There Is Any Linear Amount
Of Memory To Compute Median
Only So So What We End Up So What We Do If We See
Query With Median In It Then We Don't
Compute we don't maintain the input
stream that maintains e
approximates and we compute
the error to within multiplicative error of
nps and minus
a the space that you need
is logical in the range of values ​​to
you actually see in rta in the
case pro
y  If you have any problem like median you could use careful representation and if you are willing
to let error you can  Get By We Have Much
Slur Memory
As So How It Really Works It You
Give Me The Expression e And We Compile This
Into Some Kind Of Streaming Evaluator
It's Like An AFA But Ments A Little More
State To Maintain Intermediate
Results It Makes Just One Linear Time
Pass over the stream memory usage depends
on what you are trying to do at least
linear
but in some cases we can actually give you constant
memory
usage if median is also used than we can give you and you are willing
to tolerate error than we can give
you  Low memory usage even then
so let me do a little bit of switch and
bet over here to show you the results so this is how it
actually we implemented this algorithm
not for sigma star to aa but sigma
star to gamma star string to string
transformation very
Why Complicated
Transformations How Do You Format Btake
Files Replace Names of Authors and
Transformations Like
That The Expression Size R Things The Size of
the ST Was Something Like 3000 and 4000 Then
Align Btake Over Here
A And What I Really Want You to See Is Too
Things first linear time passes with the
stream length second and the through puts that we're
getting over here are still in the ranges
of 10000 kilobytes at 10000 characters per
second and this is a very dumb
implementation in some sense so we don't
Optimized Performance Still
Getting Regionally
Acceptable Thru Puts From This
So I'll Switch Tracks Over Here I'll Ask Another
Question What Functions Can Queries
Express A We're Making Good Time Or I
Think 40 Minutes
OK What Functions Can Queries
Express A This Is This  Is Coming As A
Programming Language Researcher
And When You Saw Sigma Star To So
Sigma Star To Bool We're Very
Familiar With This From Traditional Theory
Of Computation Courses Why Automata Are Stream
Acceptors But How Do You
Express Functions
In An Automate Model So You Could  Tire of Fight
State Transducer Sigma Star to Gamma
Star But That Dozen Work for Sigma Star
to Come How Do You
Compute What Kind of Automate Model Takes a
Stream and Outputs a Number Instead
So a Couple of Years Ago We Introduced This Model Called
Cost
Resistor Automate  I won't describe this in
a lot of detail but what it really has is it's
an automaton structure under the so
give a few set of states there is also a
few set of resistors because it's
computing an output
a transition
network I'm not familiar with.  Dotted
transition networks a but if they are what they
sound like then yes those are very similar they give
or so so really you have on transition a you
update t to t+ 1 and make
transition those
things have interesting closure
property so I can do things like
regular  Look Ahead I Don't Really Need To Say
On Transition A Make This Thing I Can Say If
The Enter Suffix That I've Seen Has Some
Property Than Make The Transition And I'm
Really Not Increasing Expressive Power At All
I Can Say Things Like O Give  Me the
entire input stream in reverse I will I can still
compute the same function so they are also
closed under input reversal so there is
semantic with respect to time in some sense
so they have nice closure
properties
regular so fat tota ins classical result
60 ect to  Formula you can write in
monet second order
logic function you can express
using this using ser ect to so
definable string term
transpose so if we
accept the ser are the model for
automate model for function then the theorem
in the main therm in  The proof in the papers is one of these
myths is that you can compute exactly the function you can
express. I
will not describe how this proof works
in any detail. Actually writing the expression
into automata is a relatively
straight forward task. It's just the  We would convert
regular expression into
f. going the other way converting enough into
regular expression is slightly more even thing kind of
like the Bellman algorithm it is more
complicated in our case because we are also
dealing with data and data flow so we
have to  Set Up This Nested Induction
Hypos This Nested Induction Now How Data
Flow Work and Make Share Take into Account Doing the
Compilation
But the Ultimate Term The Function You Can Express
Minutes Concluding
the Presentation So What I
Describe Quant Reg Expressions and What They Really Are
A Programming
Abstraction to Describe Stream
Transformations When One of You One Properties You Want to
Express Has This Temporal Nature That
Day End of Days Follows a Sequence of
Transactions End of Month  Follow a
sequence Follow a sequence of steps are a good fit for
expressing functions in the
setting There are
really three key ideas in the whole
presentation that
you do not want to be
mapping streams to individual numerical
values ​​that you want to be  Mapping
streams to include terms potentially with holes if you want
fast evaluation
algorithms you want static ambiguous checking
so else if you want DOM to be disjoined if you want
memory usage to be
bounded then you can use the term compression
algorithms when you have just a  Few
operators
and the main claims that we made were that
the class of functions that you can use are
gnostic of the cost domain of
interest
so if you are interested in neural queries then
you can use the numerical operators if you are
interested in string
transformations.  You can use strings with
Kkane and you get a programming
language string
transformation they can express a whole
class of function so it's not like you have
extra features and you get a slightly more
expressive class which is close under many
of the proper features  The Traditional
Transformation You Would Think Of Na Ta
Streams And We Also Give You We Also
Present Fast Evaluation Algorithms For This So We So I Present Few Direction Future
Work The Most Important Thing That I Want
To Work Now Is The Application Of
Programming Languages ​​Na  Automata Three to
Streaming Data in
General So Because of Streaming in Particular We Have
Large Data Processing System Lock As Stem We Are
Coming Up and So As Stem It Yourself
in Our View
Describes How Data Flows Around This
Network What QI Are How Do You
Transform a Single  Streams of data so I
think are an
excellent way to actually program individual
transformations in larger
pipelines What I haven't talked about and what I
think is a very important problem is how you do join
of streams because joins are I think
the  Fundamental problem with streaming data how do
you join to streams coming to
you
online I think the connection to automata is actually with
multi tape automata if you have two tapes and
you can only go right between each tape and that kind of thing.
Function as
you express I think there are connections to be seen
over the
paralyzing why evaluation so what I
presented was a single threaded model
and actually one of the Magas group here has
worked on paralyzing some of the automata
models with processor level threads.  Level
Parallax But Really What We Might Also Be
Interested In Is Data Center Level
Parallelism So Imagine We Were Writing Code
For Google.com And There Are Many
Servers Which Are Hosting Google.com Some
Of The Streams Are Local And Some Other Part Or
Sm locally is a small
survey physical subset of air stream but
logically only the single source of data can we express this kind of
data center level PAM
can and automatically run at
scale and come up in fact with special further
sum work.
Learning Stream Transformations Can We
Learn the Kind of Why We Form Input
Output
Data Because Many Data Analysts Are Not Really True as
Programmers They Don't Want to Use
Full Programming Languages ​​We Really Want to Know
Input Output Amp We Want to Learn from Them
Slightly  Unrelated All this is also
the algorithms that I presented have
applications in the broader cyber physical
systems community
so the setting is imagine an automotive
engineer working at the same because
the real world is complicated they rely
on simulation but really what we want to see
I how close the engine rpm to
5000 so if I give you two engine one which
rpm is 3000 and another which is engine
rpm go to
4500 the engine which is lower better
satisfy this property the engine
rpm is 5000 so we can
The Calculus I Presented Natural Fit
for Expressing This Kind of Queries A
How Can We Help Them in
Monitoring Cyber ​​Physical Systems
Online
A I Already Did a Bit of the Generalization
When I Said We're Not Working with a
Single Class of Functions  You Tell Us What
Cost Operators Are Evolved But There Are Other Transformations There Are Other Cost
Domas Where This Is More Evolved What If You Had
Tree
Transducers Tree to Tree to Tree and
String to Tree Transducers What Kind of What Do You
Look Like in That
World But But More Broadly
My If You Ask Me To Describe What
My Research Is About It Is About
Simplifying Programming So Ignore All
The Technical Details In Ten Talks What I
Presented Was A Way To Describe Pro
Transformation And
Streams Hopefully Completely Simpler Than Actually
Writing  Straight line python code and
straight line c+py code to do the same thing
so we took a look at this question a few times during the
thesis it self so
new
abstracts arise with how do you do code
search with natural language so instead of for
example  Going to ask you this
in Visual Studio and what it gives
you are piece of code that outputs rather than actually giving you
point you to web
pages
a program synthesis is exactly how you would if I give
you constraints on function
how  X synthesize functions that setfai
two constrictive
Question the Contesting The Common Interest
in Right Now is Houd Vy
Use Open Source Code Carpus Things Like Gib Did not
Exist 10 Years 10 year
Open
Source Can We Learn from the Way People
Actually Write Programs to Improve
Programs Program Analysis Tools Can We Give Better
Program Synthesis
Tools Around This So I'm Actually
Excited Particularly Interested
in Answering This Question A One
Specific Part of This Would Actually Be
Going to Search  Engines Like
Google's Do Programmers Actually Ask About
Programming Languages ​​That Would
Actually Help In Knowing What Kind of
Questions We Need To Answer A
But Really A My Ideal The Ideally
Speaking The Research That I Do Has This
Blend Of A Theory And Pragmat Jam On Both
Sides So some of the three The thesis work
itself raises a bunch of interesting thematic
problems how do you do equivalence
checking and this lets you solve
constraints on strings so those are all
deep theoretical questions which I also hope to answer
in the  Future A Stop Here Thank
You
So We Have A
Question
We evaluate ease of
use of a program of productivity but if you accept that
regular expressions are some
times more natural than automata than a similar
reasoning would take you to think they are some
times easier to write than
it is a matter of collection.
You could compile one of two if not elementary in the following so so I said this
defined if
the split
Is Unique So When You Go From Regular
Expressions To NF A You Don't Really Care About This You Just
Create An Alan
Transition From This AF To That We Need To Actually Add
Additional Parts To This
Transformation To Make Sure That This Check
Holds A But
Yes  If you actually think about what our
evaluation algorithm is doing it is doing something similar but it is
doing it
casually it is it is not building up the state
space explicitly it is in it is a very
on demand construction of
state space
so what we really  It's the number of states
of the machine if it's exponential but you can
represent the states in a small amount of
space as well as do the same thing as the
whole state takes as much space as you mention exponent only while it seems like they are
Quite
Similar It's Right A to Quite  Still
if you were wondering how big
the terms grew then you would still have to do things like
term compression but it is just
following the graph to evaluate a C for many we actually need
to build the graph as we are going along and that
is  The
Complicated
Part Related Question Now if you talk in terms
of program synthesis and learning
representation you have a much more compact
representation and there are other more
compact representations you would search over i thq are
a good representation what we would need to do
In fact we have work in
progress about actually learning some of those
things is an adding extra
communication here oops
it's a few slides down or
right here I say this set of communication
so in principle you can if you search over all
the expressions you  Build up using ten
commensuration
searching
algorithms to make it practical We need to do
syntactic sugar Yes
functions that people generally express like reverse
stream A function that people generally express
reverse can be written using this
but they are just giant monolithic blocks
that are generally useless  To synthesize on their own
so just instead of having 10 com binet yer would have
30 and 40 and you'd learn with the
bigger question of do the designer
specify those and are they also learn while selling them
or so that is we don't really
I can  Answer the question
that our justification right now so we are in the
world of bash pal and said and also we said that by
manual analysis of two
programs we know that there are all these
routines in pal which we should express over here
so for
example regular  Expressions and
things like that so we just added these things because we felt they were important but yes there is what we specify
Basic The 20
Extra
Combinations What are
the Benchmarks Are There Any Data
Sets That You Would Want to Loot Against of
Different Time Types of  Tasks So There Are Lots of Buts Another Thing About People Write
Bach
Script and They Upload Them Can We Learn the
Same Bach Script Dos and the Task Program
Actually Want to Do We Should Perform Well
on Dos Tasks
and How Will We Not Be
So the
most things the programmers actually want to do are just simple
so the they are about
expressions of size 30 and 40 so when I actually
presented this
graph here this is an expression of size
3000 but most things the programmers actually
want are over here
A but I think the deeper question that you want to ask is can we
learn practically or at all for those kinds of
things
can we actually do the
learning that is harder to answer I think we can
learn all the simplest  Things That
Programmers Want to Do and a Few of the More
Complicated
Ones There Are Lots of Queries That Throw Our
Learning Algorithms Off and Still
Work in
Progress
But here's more
Transformation and the basic premise a just things like
is an alphabet is upper
case is a
digit but what we actually do actually because
of this completeness issue is
a we learning from input output example
so we pick up all these predictions
for each individual letter
prediction that  We can make from them
a so well I imagine your character as an actor and rational
and we have appreciated that that
is a bigger open problem
in the In the Program Synthesis Community How Do You How Do
You  Learn Symbolic
Automate doesn't give you a very convincing answer to that yet so yes that that is something that I should have included right here many
slides
down right here how you learn Symbolic
Automator how to go back to your bun code
search so what are the so  Okay so there's some
sort of machine learning evolved into this
part of the work so what you think where
machine learning can play a role in a
in program synthesis and generally in the
problems that you that we're discussing
so so  There are two parts to this the tool that I
that Jason and Yousef
and I were working on in MSR Cambridge was
natural language code search so there is a
lot of natural language processing developed
in just taking this this sentence over here
and figuring  Out Something That We're
Program Analysis People Can Think
About
Query We Did We Choose This Particular Space
of Code Over Other Spaces of Code We Probably Also Did The Same Thing
So There Is
Machine Learning To Be Done Over Others Wisely
On I We Discuss This To Magas All People
Write Code In Python And JavaScript  At the
time we are strictly on languages ​​but
really if I wrote a function for you like say
def let of l blah blah blah there
is nothing formal over here set this
is a list but most programmers have that in mind saying that
this argument is a
List that the return type is an
injury These are not formal contracts They are informal
in the mental world view and
documentation And that we can learn this kind of thing
So there is some work on Grul
typing for Python but all that is again
based on  Programmers Making Enosh on Their Own We Can
Learn Those Things Because We Have So Much Code
Out There  What Kind
of Be
Needed and What Have You Laddie
Experimented With and What Would You Want to Do Would
You Like to
Investigate or So So This Is Extremely Simple
Work in Progress I Wouldn't Put My
Fet in My Mouth But What I Think We Really
Need to be doing is some kind
of mixture so how easily see this in here you
have
how much
code right so we have things like gib over here
all the code that is available on gib and then they
are how
much a i don't know how  Much running how many
runs so you have tools like Sage from
MSR you have tools like dakan which take a
single program and basically run across
so I think there are
sos Sage and even swim the bang code search
tool wa over here I think there is more
To be done in this whole thing where you can say
things like aha every so can i build a
world view without saying where is l if and then the length
of l a then i say something like aha so then i have
a priority on l being a
Is a List Probability of
This is thing stuff that you can do because
of Gib we should also be exploring what Sage
and Dacan and projects like that do which take a
single program and run it to
action I think let's thank you again for gk
and